it's time to cheer on your favorite team
this season with a delicious spray
spread that won't break the calorie make
register dietitian nutritionist Mia sin
has delicious appetizers meals and
drinks to make and serve at your next
tailgate or Home gate hey Las Vegas now
it's officially football season and I
everything you need to put together a
healthy and delicious tailgate or
homegate spread starting with a seven
layer dip for this seven layer
Mediterranean dip start with hummus and
layer with chopped cucumber tomato red
onion feta olives and pine nuts I use
fresh Cravings hummus because it's
creamy delicious and made with a short
list of high quality whole food
ingredients that enhance flavor like
chickpeas Savory tahini and Chilean
extra virgin olive oil it comes in a
variety of flavors including classic
roasted garlic and honey jalapeno you
can find it in the deli section at
Walmart for this seven layer taco dip
start with refried beans and topped with
sour cream salsa cheese green onion
diced tomato and olives fresh craving
salsa is a refrigerated instead of
Jarred never cooked or pasteurized and
comes in a range of heat levels and
flavor varieties you can find it chilled
in the produce section at Walmart
another game day appetizer that everyone
can get on board with is roasted sweet
potato wedges these are made with goat
cheese a pomegranate glaze and crunchy
pistachios I work with the wonderful
company wonderful pistachios are a good
naturally cholesterol free source of
complete protein with 6 grams per
serving and 3 grams of fiber plus about
90 percent of the fats found in
pistachios are unsaturated so you get a
trio of nutrients that may help keep you
Fuller longer roast the sweet potato
wedges with olive oil pepper and salt
drizzle with the pomegranate honey glaze
and top with goat cheese and pistachios
for nutrient-dense crunch for the main
course we have two ingredients slow
cooker meatballs with a veggie forward
twist I started with the flame broiled
Italian style meatballs by Farm Rich who
makes America's most popular game day
snacks and appetizers that are great to
have in the freezer for impromptu
tailgate Gatherings you can find them in
the freezer aisle at the grocery store
including Albertsons Vons and Walmart
just check the store locator at
farmridge.com then add this barbecue
sauce by true made foods which is a
veteran-owned company that makes
America's favorite condiments that are
sweetened with fruit and vegetables
instead of added sugar cook on low for
six hours and serve on their own or out
of rolls
finally cheer on your favorite team with
spiced Palm cider simply simmer your
warm spices with the zest and juice of
half an orange 8 ounces of water and 32
ounces of palm wonderful 100 pomegranate
juice then strain Palm wonderful 100
pomegranate juice is a healthy fridge
staple and a simple delicious way to
fuel your body with antioxidants every
bottle has the juice of whole pressed
pomegranates and nothing else no fillers
and never any added sugar sometimes
Foods lose antioxidants when cooked but
not so with pomegranate juices
polyphenol antioxidants when cooking
with pomegranate juice it retains its
antioxidant goodness I hope you enjoyed
these healthy tailgate recipes you can
find everything on my website
nutritionbymia.com and you can also
pre-order my new book mostly plant-based
available on Amazon barnesandnoble.com
and wherever books are still